bonsoir céline mariani merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on
commence avec cette nouvelle de la
soirée un accord donc validée sur le
plan de relance c'est une nouvelle dont
vous réjouissez écoutez c'est conforme à
la tradition européenne où après des
réunions marathon la salle a été
tellement marathon il ya finalement un
accord qui est trouvé c'est un peu tôt
pour se dire si les informations qu'on a
parce qu'on n'a pas encore toutes les
informations cet accord vient juste
d'être annoncé 6 qui est le gagnant qui
est le père temps mais l'essentiel j'ai
envie de dire c'est que d'abord la
hongrie et la pologne ont marqué qu'on
pouvait résister et finalement je pense
en or une sorte de victoire tactique
puisque les éléments d'information dont
on dispose aujourd'hui c'est quoi à
cette heure ci on nous dit en réalité la
pologne et la hongrie
on va accepter la question de l'état de
droit
mais en cas de litige cet état de droit
sera soumis à la cour européenne de
justice ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui
veut dire en clair que il y aurait une
victoire j'ai presque envie de dire
tactique de monsieur urban et de la
pologne pourquoi parce que quand on
connaît les mécanismes d'application des
décisions de la cour européenne de
justice en réalité c'est extrêmement
compliqué et il ya peu de chance qu'un
jour cela arrive je vais dire à être
efficace et mai et une victoire de
monsieur urban parce que finalement avec
la pologne ils toucheront les aides que
l'union européenne avait touché par
contre j'ai envie de dire c'est si c'est
une victoire quand puisqu'ils auront ses
formes
c'est aussi à peut-être un peu une
défaite je trouve paradoxal que sur les
principes
finalement il décide de se soumettre à
la justice européenne une fois de plus
les mariannes et justement justement
avant même en attendant l'issue de ce
sommet le ministre hongrois des affaires
étrangères s'était félicité à l'issue du
bras de fer parlant d'une victoire
on nous a informés que l'accès de la
hongrie au fonds européen ne serait pas
liée à des conditions politiques ou
idéologiques
une réaction justement cette déclaration
oui là c'est clairement une victoire là
dessus c'est clairement une victoire
puisque en réalité
pour faire simple qu'est ce qui s'était
passé d'abord il y avait eu d'accord sur
un plan pour aider les différents pays
européens
dans le second temps un certain nombre
de pays européens ont dit oui mais il
faut des conditions sur ce fameux
respect de l'état de droit ou en réalité
on sait pas vraiment très précisément ce
que ça recoupe l'on peut tout y mettre à
jour c'est ça le véritable danger et à
la aujourd'hui clairement le plan
européen pour s'appliquer n'exige plus
ce respect de l'état de droit par la
pologne et par la hongrie et donc ceux
qui voulaient bloquer les subventions
pour ces deux pays
ou plutôt soumettre ses subventions à
une condition dès maintenant
eh bien on réellement perdu le sommet
européen qui va évidemment se consacrer
à la crise pandémique en europe 1
malheureusement ça se passe mal en
europe l'europe qui accueille désormais
de montrer qu'elle avance d'une même
voix face au virus contrairement à ce
qu'elle avait fait lors de la première
vague c'est toujours le rêve de dire
qu'on avance d'une même voix d'une même
voix mais en réalité là l'affrontement
convient de voir entre deux ou trois
pays puisque je rappelle que la slovénie
soutenait aussi la hongrie et la pologne
et le reste des pays européens montrent
qu'il ya deux conceptions durable au
sein de l'union européenne
c'est à dire ceux qui comme monsieur
macron par exemple madame merkel
souhaitent que petit à petit les états
s'efface au profit de l'union européenne
et ceux qui considèrent que l'union
européenne doit être avant tout un
regroupement de nations comme monsieur
victor urban comme la pologne comme la
slovène comme la slovaquie et je rajoute
aussi comme marine le pen et le parti
que nous représentons au parlement
européen et donc cette différence de
conception de la vision européenne elle
perdure alors la stratégie de
vaccination
qu'est ce que vous en attendez thierry
mariani est ce que l'europe sera la
haute
pour vous on voit le royaume uni s'est
beaucoup commenté un qui a pris une
longueur d'avancé
le ministre de la santé qui a même
évoqué le break sic en dix ans et grâce
aux breaks site votre sentiment sur ce
point écoutez d'abord j'attends que il
est absolument pas de réglementation au
niveau européen ce qui serait totalement
illégal pour imposer à tous les pays
les mêmes mesures je crois qu'il faut
que chaque pays puisse choisir par
exemple au niveau français nous sommes
extrêmement attachés à ce que cette
vaccination soit sur la base du
volontariat et en aucun cas sur une base
obligatoire
ensuite on jugera quand la campagne sera
fini on a vu clients européenne à titre
préventif à acheter toute une série de
médicaments de vaccins
cependant dans certains n'étaient même
pas encore opérationnel on voit ce qui
se passe sur leurs âmes désir on verra
ce qui se passe sur d'autres médicaments
c'est un peu tôt pour juger au cas
arriver d'avant des discussions de ce
sommet également le break site les
négociations toujours dans le brouillard
sur la future relation commerciale entre
lieux et le royaume-uni forte
possibilité qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
avec lui et nous a dit boris johnson du
côté de la présidente de la commission
et bien c'est pareil je vous propose
d'écouter ursula von der leyen et le
troisième sujet sera certainement le
break site j'ai eu une très longue
conversation hier soir avec le premier
ministre boris johnson
c'était une bonne conversation mais
c'est difficile nous sommes disposés à
accorder l'accès au marché unique à nos
amis britanniques
c'est le plus grand marché unique du
monde mais les conditions doivent être
équitables elles doivent être équitables
pour nos travailleurs et les entreprises
et cet équilibre d'équité n'a pas été
atteint jusqu'à présent nos négociateurs
travaillent toujours et nous prendrons
une décision dimanche que ce jeûne en
deçà mais voilà pédo du pessimisme à des
deux côtés je le rappelle forte
possibilité qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
avec lui et c'est ce qu'elle dit boris
johnson ce soir c'est du bluff ou on est
parti pour un odile thierry mariani si
trop tôt pour le dire mais si je devais
parier je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
d'accord je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
d'accord parce qu'on a encore des
différends fondamentaux ni entre les
européens et les britanniques sur trois
fois d'abord le premier c'est la
gouvernance et les moyens de régler les
différends futur c'est à dire quand il y
aura des accords entre la grande
bretagne et l'union européenne à qui on
va confier j'allais dire le jugement
c'est différent que demande l'union
européenne elle demande à ce que le
jugement de ces différents soit confiée
à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
bien sûr les britanniques refusent parce
qu'il est évident que la cour de justice
de l'union européenne
et quand même fortement liée à l'union
européenne donc les britanniques ne
veulent pas de ceux de ce cette instance
pour juger les différents deuxième gros
différent c'est ce qu'on appelle le
level playing field c'est-à-dire en
clair une garantie de concurrence loyale
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire en clair
que les européens
et là c'est une bonne condition que les
européens demandent à ce que les normes
qui ont été adoptés demeure par les
britanniques du temps où il était dans
l'union européenne demeure quoi qu'il
arrive c'est à dire en clair que si les
britanniques négocient un traité se
pensent qu'ils sont en train de faire
avec les états unis il n'y ait pas un
accord qui ensuite met notamment les
normes phytosanitaires ou les normes
sanitaires en dessous du niveau où elles
sont aujourd'hui en clair c'est un
accord qui dit on peut pas avoir des
conditions
on désormais plus favorables pour toute
une série de productions en grande
bretagne est donc là c'est une les
britanniques le refuse pour le moment et
je pense que l'union européenne la
raison de tenir là dessus et dernier
point c'est la pêche alors la pêche
c'est pas énorme en terme de volume mais
c'est très important pour les pêcheurs
français puisqu'en moyenne les pêcheurs
français font de 30% de leur capture
dans les eaux territoriales britanniques
qu'est ce que demande l'union européenne
elle demande à ce qu'il ya une accord
pour des quotas de pêche puisqu'à
l'heure actuelle les britanniques ont
par exemple d'accord avec les norvégiens
vous avec les norvégiens ne sont pas
dans l'union européenne et donc en
réalité il y aura un accord sur des
quotas de pêche mais les briques les
britanniques valen accords annuels
l'union européenne va un accord sur dix
ans pour avoir une certaine visibilité
et donc là visiblement il n'y a toujours
pas d'accord mais soyons clair l'union
européenne a aussi un moyen de rétorsion
c'est que n'oublions pas que les
produits de la pêche britannique péché
par les pêcheurs britannique ce land
aussi sur le territoire européen et donc
sur ces trois points
aujourd'hui il ya un désaccord on a par
le plus de l'irlande puisque visiblement
un accord a été trouvé rapidement j'ai
sur les briques 6 à ce que je voulais
aussi vous avoir votre sentiment sur sur
la turquie mais vous craignez vous
clairement des conséquences d'un odile
non sincèrement non il y aura quelques
complications administratives
on voit par exemple les fils de poids
lourds qui s'allonge mais non je pense
que si un odile a bien écouté il ya
plein de pays avec lesquels on n'a pas
d'accord avec l'union européenne
c'est dans la logique de boris johnson
ils voulaient le break site il peut pas
à la fois quitté l'europe et avoir un
accord qui le lie totalement aux mêmes
conditions que d'autres pays avec
l'europe
donc ça ne surprend pas dernier dossier
très en vue lors de ce sommet européen
la turquie avec la question des
sanctions que contre rancart à la france
sera bien
seul sur ce dossier la france une fois
de plus celle de khaled man c'est à dire
qu'on sait très bien que la chancelière
est très on va dire favorables relations
avec la turquie
et on voit qu'à chaque fois et bien
c'est cette position qui l'emportent
voilà je vous rappelle quand même que la
france par exemple vous voulez quelques
sanctions contre la turquie a là aucune
n a aucune
la turquie ne respectent rien je vous
rappelle qu encore des journalistes il
ya peu de temps sont décédées dans les
prisons de turquie pour des grèves de la
faim au temps j'allais dire l'union
européenne est forte avec les faibles on
voit par exemple les sanctions qu'on
applique sur le belarus autant la
turquie est faible avec les forts il ya
aucune sanction il ya des discussions il
ya des reproches faits à la turquie est
un dernier exemple pour montrer bien la
position allemande
quand la france a demandé le boycott des
armements sur la turquie l'allemagne s'y
opposer et on constate que l'allemagne
continue à vendre des armes à la turquie
donc monsieur erdogan peut dormir sur
des idées et ses oreilles sans aucun
problème il a une alliée dans la place
avec madame merkel merci thierry mariani
député européen du rassemblement
national d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france pour commenter donc ce
sommet européen actuellement à bruxelles
merci à vous